i'm not here to write stories i've seen
a million times i'm here to write
stories i haven't seen a million times
if you only had three rules in which to
guide your screenplay
what writing rules would those be
make sure
make sure that all the characters are
distinctive from each other and have
their own distinctive way of speaking
and
know what
they care about know what they want
know them write them as as people not as
generic cab driver generic and whatever
anything um
tell a story
that pays off
in a meaningful way and not just for the
main character but try and have it pay
off in an emotionally satisfying way for
a variety of your characters
um
and um and have something fresh in it
fresh and fresh and meaningful
so that it isn't something you've seen a
million times i'm not here to write
stories i've seen a million times i'm
here to write stories i haven't seen a
million times
and
and that doesn't mean it can't be
inspired by the tradition i write in and
it's fun like for instance in space
command all the space command personnel
are named after famous science fiction
writers i grew up reading so there's
cemack and sturgeon and bradbury and you
know le guin and and so forth and that's
very fun and the funny thing was at one
point i had a character named murray
leinster after science fiction writer
from the 50s and uh and i cast victor
manso who's latino and i thought well he
doesn't look like a marie leinster so
then i had to think of a science fiction
or fantasy writer a latino one and
finally i remembered jorge louis borges
who's a great fantasist uh from
argentina and so i named the character
jorge borges and uh so that was fun that
was very fun so uh but i just you know i
but i would just make sure it has to be
original truthful the characters have to
be vivid and it has to has to take us to
an emotional place that's satisfying
those are the those are the big ones
and
i mean a film can
have a lot of drawbacks for instance no
one script is going to be everything to
everybody you know you can't like for
instance you might want to write
something about transgender rights at
some point and maybe maybe you'll put in
a transgender character in one script or
maybe ultimately you want to write about
that in a big way that that might be the
the main drive of your story but again i
don't ever write
message things you know you have to have
a story that's engaging elaine will
start with themes i rarely do i usually
start with a character or an actor that
i want to work with or
it can be on almost anything it can be
almost anything and
but i always arrive at the same place
which is a story that i want to tell
so just as there's the bechdel test
is there a message test so that we
as filmmakers okay yeah you know you
know that that it's a message uh film if
when the lights come up everyone's gone
you know so
you know i mean
you know i mean rod rod certainly used
to be very cognizant he had a lot to say
uh you know politically and socially but
he knew that you had to create
characters that the
the people cared about like when burgess
meredith is the last man on earth you
care about him you're engaged by that
man
and uh and you feel sorry for him what
happens to him you know it's uh
i mean i don't know any
really good writers who don't put the
focus on character in science fiction
you know whether it's deckard and blade
runner or whomever you know there's
people that you care about uh ripley and
aliens i mean great example uh you have
to there's there's so many films and tv
shows where you don't care about the
people and you don't and it's just
forgettable it's just forgettable so
it's uh
really important to to do that and uh
you know and and again i'm not here to
change everyone's opinion my goal of
skit is to convince people to be
compassionate and convince people to be
that that the power of love
is important that we're
we are united
by our commonality far more than we're
divided by our
opinions
you know and so that's what i would urge
people to recognize you know and uh so
that's i mean my big message is
compassion and uh
that's a good message i think to have
why do we care about ellen ripley
we hear about ripley because she's
she
well first of all in aliens she cares
about someone other than herself she's
trying to save that little girl even if
she dies she's willing to sacrifice
herself but also she's the smartest
person in that movie she's the most
competent person in that movie that
story is about her where she starts
traumatized and step by step by step to
save other people she has to take
control and command she knows what she's
doing and the fact and and again it's a
great marriage between character and
actress because corny weaver is able to
play a powerful woman where she's no
less feminine she's just competent and
and you believe every single thing she
does in that movie it's terrific it's
one of my favorite films it's a great
film
how was she received how was that
character received at that time well
it's very funny when alien came out you
know originally
ripley was a male character and they
change through a female character and
and i thought it was great but my
brother jim my brothers grew up in
orange county i grew up in l.a when my
parents divorced when i was three and my
brother jim said oh man that woman she
was such a he was like so
traditional now i think he'd have a
different opinion he was young back then
but it's like he was from a much more
conservative background it was like you
know so he was like um
riled up about having a woman character
that's wrong but i thought it was just
great i loved it from the first
so and that was what 83 79 79 oh sorry
79 aliens was 70 was 86. but the fun
part was
um uh before the pandemic 2019
i heard that there was a high school
there was a high school in east in
bergen new jersey and it was
the the art teacher and the english
teacher had an idea that instead of
doing like you know brigadoon or
oklahoma for their high school play they
would do alien the entire movie and they
built everything from scratch the aliens
uh suit the the 15 foot space jockey the
space suits the chest burster everything
and they thought they'd just fly under
the radar that no one would hear about
just parents would come see it but then
of course it went viral so ridley scott
put up some money and they were able to
put on another performance
and they were in the eye of the media
storm and so i flew to new jersey
north bergen new jersey to spend the day
talking to the students so because i
knew they were going to get a lot of
promises from hollywood and i knew those
would all be
false probably and would fall flat and
their hearts would get broken and i want
to say here's how it works and if you
come to l.a i'm happy to to guide you
and you can all be members of my round
table wherever you are and so forth and
so i spent the day with them and then as
a surprise
uh sigourney weaver showed up and she
hung out with the kids and she
introduced the play and it was just
wonderful i actually posted the entire
play on mr sci-fi
and it's so great when the chessburster
comes out there's blood everywhere it
was wonderful and and i said to them i
said the kids
this is hollywood what you're doing
right here is hollywood hollywood is
wherever you're creating something
that has meaning something that you gave
it your really best effort
and uh and it was a i'm so glad i went
it was a wonderful experience that's
great i'll have to check it out yeah
we'll put a link below this video it's
really fun awesome well people can watch
you know the first hour of space command
they can watch the bonus episode they
can watch that they can watch my just
sulu star trek episode all on mr sci-fi
sure are you in elaine yeah yeah just
it's super fun
yeah it's enjoyable and then we can see
your dogs too i love the fact that i get
to have my own network i mean
i wasn't planning that i just had lunch
with glenn mazzera who was a friend of
mine who was the show runner on walking
dead and we were having lunch and he
said you know you know so much about
science fiction you should have your own
youtube channel and i thought
good idea and so
so i called it mr sci-fi and just
started it up i didn't do anything
really to promote it now as i said we've
had millions of hits and uh
closing in on 100 000 subscribers and it
was just like great because i can i can
do something short or something that
takes a lot more effort but um
you know it's it's really fun because
i'm so
so enthusiastic about science fiction
i've loved it since i was a kid and sulu
why should we care about sulu
well
when i was a kid watching star trek sulu
was my favorite character and because
george k was just so great and he was so
smart and so competent and loyal and
honorable and just wonderful and he
never got the great sulu episode and i
then found out
that there were a group of fans in
upstate new york making their own star
trek episodes and walter kanye who
played chekhov was flying up there to
make an episode about his character and
dorothy fontana who story added the
original star trek had written that
script so icon and my friend michael
reeves back when they were going to
bring star trek back as a series in the
70s came up with this great sulu story
and so i contacted the guys in upstate
new york and i said listen michael and i
both wrote for star trek the next
generation the michael's an emmy winner
uh
would you be interested in doing this
episode and they said sure and i said
but i want to direct it and they said
fine and um and so then i went to george
and i i typed up the outline of what the
story was going to be
and i said uh look you you never got the
great zulu episode you you deserved
and i said this is it and so he said i'm
in
and
michael and i wrote the script and it
took me six months to prep
and uh to a solid year we shot we shot
it in a matter of two weeks and then it
was solid year of editing and visual
effects had 700 visual effects shots and
when we were shooting i said to george
next year you and i will be on in japan
speaking to the world science fiction
convention and screening this episode
after which we'll answer questions and
you'll be answering in japanese because
he's fluent in japanese and i'll be
answering english and i said a year
after that will be nominated for the
hugo which is the top award in science
fiction and all of that happened
oh wow and uh so because it was i'm i'm
proud
i'm very very proud of that episode and
it's every every i gave every bit of
everything i knew how to do in that to
write and direct and exactly produced
that
and my contract was that no one could
touch a frame of it i had total um
directorial say and so it's exactly what
i wanted to be and as i say we cast
christina moses and she's phenomenal
every take was just gorgeous and i'm and
i've worked with her since she's in
space command now as well as being in
the middle million little things on abc
um but she uh and she'll be in magic
time and and some of the other projects
we're doing so um
it's fun you build an ensemble of
friends who who you love to work with
how much of what you write is trying to
be original versus trying to give the
audience what they want well
i'm pleased when the audience gets value
from what i do
but that's not
why i'm doing it
i'm doing it because
i
have something i want to say
something i have experienced or
something i've observed that's
meaningful to me
and
i it's so
and and there's just so many wonderful
pieces i mean
the lovely part about what i do because
of it's science fiction i get to create
a universe
and that's the thing that science
fiction brings that other genres don't
tend to if if you see a story set in the
modern day
it's just about those people it's about
that story but if you tell a really good
science fiction story the universe is a
separate
character in a way like for instance
blade runner you can do stories in the
blade runner universe you can do stories
in the star wars universe or star trek
universe and that's extremely
beguiling and i love that and it allows
you also to work with visual design and
because i was a painting sculptor and
graphic arts major i have a very strong
visual sense and i also know the history
of science fiction design i mean i think
it's incredibly cool and unexpected that
we have big silver spaceships now thanks
thanks to elon musk they look exactly
like the ones i saw in when worlds
collide or on the book book covers from
my childhood and that's just a thrill um
i love bringing a science fiction
reality to the screen it's um it just
you saw so many of my of my skills and
enthusiasms
do you think you'll be going up to space
in one of the various uh no carriers
okay let's see what happens
there's a few to choose from it's not
something that
i'm eager to do but it's not something i
wouldn't mind doing either but i do know
personally no astronauts and
scientists at nasa and jpl and all of
that stuff's really exciting so
there's a member of our roundtable who's
a science fiction writer and his day job
is he drives the mars
that's a cool thing rover has two
watches one is on earth time and one is
on mars time which is just super cool
yeah sorry i'm late i was you know right
yeah i said a crater oh wait
yeah wrong watch but yeah very fun
you